hundred of the expectations of the great
pioneers of computer science like Alan
Turing God Channel who believed that
chess could be an ultimate test for
machines to become intelligent like cute
you people realize that today machines
playing at the strengths of 33 to 3400s
when you look at the stock fish and and
Commodore on the dedicated software
which is you know it's the same
difference between them and Magnus
pearls as between Magnus Carlsen and uh
sort of a very average player from an
old anything that has a gaming element
which is will do that and that's by the
way brings us to the much bigger picture
and my conclusion is anything that we do
while knowing how we do that the shields
will do better so that's why the future
for humans action to lift for new
territories to to expand the horizons of
New Frontiers so to find out something
brand new something that we don't know
how to do and and it will be more
difficult for machines actually to catch
up